EXTEND
HE ALSO GOT THEIR ONLY GOAL IN
THE 2-1FIRST, RAFFL.
A BOUNCING PUCK AND REDIRECTED
ADVANTAGE OF AOETTINGER.
THAT IS SOMOM SPIFFY STOP
FROM ONE OF THE HOTTER SCORERS
IN THE LEAGUE.
>> Josh: BOUGUENTZEL.
GUENTZEL HAS POINTS IN HIS LAST
16 GAMES PLAYED. LEFT IT WIDE O.
DUMOULIN, A DEFENSEMAN, JUST
CREEPS DOWN THE SEASON, HE'S
BEEN LIVING OUT OF A HOTEL,
IFFY SIX ON FIVE THE OTHER
NIGHT, LED TO OVERTIME IN THE
S
AND CLAWING THEIR W W PLAYOFFS,D
BELIEF AND HE'STHEM.
WHY NOT.
>> Josh: ONE
CLANKED OFF THE POST.
THE STARS DODGE A HUGE ONE.
>> Daryl: I WOULD SUSPECT THIS
IS A PRODUCT OF PLAYING WITH
SIDNEY CRORO
SIDE.
CROSBY THROUGH HIS LEGS,
IT'S BLOCKED OUT, STOP BY
OETTINGER ON THINK OF HINTZ BLI.
THEY
SEKERA OFF THEY
GAINED CONTROL.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF KIND OF
STAND AND
PLAYED IT BACK.
DIDN'T REALIZE IT WASHEISKANEN.
>> Daryl: A GREAT HUSBAND TOLL
GET BACK. CONTACT.
HE
THE GAME.
ASTON-REESE HAS BEEN ALL OVER
ON THOSE ZONE ENTRIES.
SIMPLE STUFF, RIGHT?
>> GETET
4:00 TO PLAY NOW.
LOOKING FOR THEIR FIRST LEAD OF
THE GAME, AND THEY'REASON
ROBERTSON AT THE NET FRONT TO
EVEN CONTROL THE